varia je crois que je vois et prendre un
gros paquet de chips à l'oignon sur
iphone gestionnaire
vas-y vas-y emprunter chips oh oui c'est
une star elle mes toiles nos vallées
si vous reconnaissez l'homme du magasin
dit son numéro c'est numéro 4
c'est cet homme a gan est associée au
pacs est un tueur brutale et froid je
vous ferai entrée dans le programme
fédéral de protection de témoins tout ça
alors c'est tellement simple il n'a qu'à
pas témoigner et le cauchemar prendra
fin sa prendra fin quand tu sera
condamné je laisserai un contrat sur ta
carte et sur ta copine
le cauchemar ne prendra fin que quand
vous serez morts tous les deux non tu te
trompe c'est toi qui es mort connard je
vais te retrouver je vais te faire la
peau et disparaître et personne ne le
saura jamais je largue le programme de
protection
c'est toi qui a besoin d'être posée tu
vas me dire où je peux trouver à gan
t'auras pas les couilles il n'avait pas
fait votre travail
le trouverait mais d'ici là resté très
prudent on s'est trouvé un petit blanc
qui veut fumer à gaza
ça c'est la meilleure
allez que je passe quelque chose mais il
faut que t'arrêtes mme non non il
n'abandonnera jamais je suis obligé de
faire ça pour qu'on puisse traiter
ensemble
j'aime à le voir six pieds sous terre
seulement je suis encore une dernière
nuit après j'arrête vous n'avez qu'à pas
intervenir je compte personnellement les
garçons vous ne tuerez plus personne